what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking back up again
with the century by Jeff Lemire and
again okay I want to kind of reiterate
this for a second because the century
can be a bit of a confusing character
but it's also been a few weeks as we've
done since we did part one the first
part of the story Jeff Lemire is really
just kind of he's really doing something
new here it is really the way it is but
when it came to the century Robert
Reynolds I mean we knew about the
character of scout his sidekick we know
those characters existed but we haven't
really seen or heard from him since and
so really a lot of the stuff that's
going on here is really Jeff Lemire does
kind of operating with a blank slate
this century was the only consistent
character and the we only knew about
scout from the original call Jing is in
jail II story scout was never seen or
heard from again after those and you
know after after that original run and
so for the most part it's just kind of
left to our own devices in terms of what
happened here now what we do know is
that up to this point what it basically
happened is that with the return of the
century always comes the return of the
void wherever the century is the void
will be and this is where Jeff Lemire is
kind of messing with things again is
because this century is only really
allowed to return it kind of like this
computerized pocket dimension that
exists in the mind of Robert Reynolds as
to the void will only exist there
because that's where the century is what
this does is it basically showed that
essentially Scout had been working
alongside crania one of the former
villains of the century to basically
become the new century and so what this
does is actually show how that happened
so initiatives picked up about six weeks
ago and eventually says that at some
point in time crania was the villain of
the century he had like the tri-level
brain basically like he had a helmet
that gave him mental powers or at least
you know enhanced his mental mental
abilities and then he had like three
chimpanzee brains inside that helmet
which is just for show and then he would
face off against the century the nature
of that the nature of cranial is not
really designed to be taken seriously
and I imagine a lot people probably look
at that and say well that kind of sounds
silly I mean it was it really will it
really is designed to be that way
because River this century is grounded
in the idea that he was like this
old-school 1960s character that was
quote-unquote forgotten that Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby made that's the way his
character was originally intended to be
done and that's the way his character is
kind of maintained over the years when
it comes to introducing new concepts but
basically what had happened was that
Scout had grown essentially jealous of
the city Robert riddles and so he
desires to become the Sentry he desires
to break away from the life that he's
been living and go back to the way
things used to be when he had both arms
when he was a sidekick to the greatest
hero of all time you know that kind of
thing and he wants to go back there but
you can't and that's kind of the nature
of Jeff Lemire story here is you cannot
go back you can never go back to the way
things used to be
you can never go back to the way things
work back in the day all you can ever do
is move forward and make the best of
where you are now and look back on those
memories fondly but you can never return
to them but with scout he can't help but
do that his life is grounded in the way
things used to be a doesn't want to be
in the current moment and so when he
sits down with crania of course crania
was basically serving time in the raft
of course the raft basically being a
major superhero or super villain prison
but scout sits down with him and says
what if I told you we could find a way
to go back to the way things used to be
when you and I were like when when when
I was a sidekick of of the century and
you were the main bad guy it's
interesting here because scouts trying
to rebuild the world as he remembers it
which is a very bad thing that's a very
very very dangerous thing living in a
past will not allow you to cope with the
future it'll now it won't allow you to
cope with the here and now now there's
always something beneficial to be found
about the life you live at the moment
and I was one of those things that he
just doesn't he just simply doesn't
recognize and so what is up happening
here is Scout tells cranial look there's
a way to do this there's a way for me to
recreate the golden Guardian serum the
century serum so I can go back to being
Scout again and then you can go back to
being cranium but the responsive cranium
is look there's no way to duplicate the
serum so I'm gonna talk about that for a
second it's a nature that century I want
to talk about that so when it comes to
these century penalties these
super-powered things the Infinity
formula that basically made Nick Fury
immortal so long as he took it the serum
of dr. Cornelius and in the century all
this stems from Captain America Captain
America got the Super Soldier Serum as
was created by doctor dr. Abraham
Erskine and then Steve Rogers ingested
it Abraham Erskine died and Steve Rogers
is the only person who has it and no
one's been able to get their hands on a
blood sample of Steve Rogers in order to
basically duplicate the serum and even
for those who who seemed to have been
able to there was no way to duplicate
the Super Soldier Serum there was no way
to make more versions of it and so when
it came to that in the aftermath of the
perceived death of Captain America all
these different people and different
groups tried to recreate the formula and
what happened was a guy named dr.
Cornelius recreated it but basically
amplified it it was a thousand times
more powerful than the Super Soldier
Serum of Captain America and of course
Bob Myrtle's basically took it he
ingested it he became a century and then
that serum was given to Scout who went
on to become the sidekick and so on and
so forth and so scouts try to find a way
to duplicate that the response of
cranial is no one has the notes of dr.
Cornelius no one can duplicate the serum
of the century and that's when Scout
shows up and says actually you can't I
found the notes I found everything we
need in order to pull this off and so
time passes five weeks turns in a
for weeks turns into two weeks ago so on
and so forth and they were basically
working on a way to duplicate the serum
while the same time incapacitate Robert
Reynolds now the idea behind this was to
basically steal the device that robber
ills uses to enter into this
computerized emission you enter into his
own mind scape and then in turn kind of
keep him preoccupied and then allows
Scout to ingest the serum and then go
forward as the new century and so when
they broke into his house when they
stole this device so on and so forth
that's exactly what happened to a degree
the problem with this was that it kind
of backfired that when it comes to
Robert riddles when it comes to the
century they're basically like two minds
in the same body the best way to think
about that was like The Incredible Hulk
you've got the Bruce Banner persona and
you've got the Incredible Hulk persona
and much like you know the The
Incredible Hulk that Robert Reynolds
healed his physical form will shift I
mean when he becomes a century his
physical form changes his hair gets
longer he's a lot more muscular a lot
more lean so on and so forth you know it
actually changes the difference here is
that this century does have his own
physical form because he has his own
physical form and because he has his own
mind
it's literally swapping personalities
and so what happened here what Scout did
not account for when the century was
perceived have been locked away
basically then what had happened was
Robert Reynolds in the century had
basically switched places and so Robert
Reynolds was stuck inside his own
mindscape and the century him into the
physical world which in turn became a
question of both and what happens next
and that's literally when you end up
having a scout ingest himself with the
serum and then go forward is like a
second version of the century and the
problem with this was that where Robert
riddles himself was basically being
questioned and contained by Tony Stark
when this shift happens then it's like
oh hell like is is it's absolute panic
because the responses will in the boys
on his way whenever this century
manifests the clock starts and when the
clock starts when it counts down to zero
however long that happens to be the void
will arrive and when the void arrives
all hell will break loose and Tony Stark
immediately realizes that like he
immediately gets to freak out and say
hey look we have to contain and control
this guy this century basically leaves
and that's when you end up having Iron
Man Donna's armor and then put on the
the century Buster armor now the funny
thing about this is that Iron Man's
chasing down a guy who's already trying
to stop himself so it's like Iron Man's
trying to stop centuries trying to stop
themselves because the century
understands the danger of all this the
century's goal is to track down the
device that basically serves to allow
him to enter the mindscape and then
regain it and then allow Robert Reynolds
to go back to the way things were at
work Robert riddles exist in the real
world he goes into the mindscape and in
the century manifest and so it's almost
like Iron Man's trying to stop his own
cause as those kind of crazy now the
other
of this is that let's that's one thing
to bear in mind the centuries powers
astronomical so even with a century
Buster armor by man can't stop I mean he
never could at the very least is a
stopgap measure there's nothing you can
do I mean there's no conceivable way to
end it and so in the middle of all this
Tony Stark tries to reason with with
century and then tells it like you have
to turn around only for a server to find
out the Scout arrived here now the fight
between scout in this century is not
just a fight between two variable gods
it's almost like a fight for the mantle
of the century
Scout sees himself as the guy who should
be the new century he's like I've spent
enough time sitting in the shadows of
your life I spend enough time being this
sidekick it's my turn to be the hero now
Scouts deranged and he's really kind of
been driven insane by one his own desire
to replace century and to the massive
amount of power he's received because
that's one thing to bear in mind when it
comes to attaining this level of power
in such a short amount of time it drives
people crazy this injury for example
when he first ingested the golden
formula he basically became a drug
addict it got to a point where he was
like running up on on the per professor
cornelius and just being like dude I
need men I need to see a man like I need
some more that serum dude like I mean I
need it it became a drug for him and so
in that moment with these two fighting
each other there's not a whole lot that
Ironman can do here the other half of
this is that cranial really kind of
reasons well then we have to keep Robert
we have to keep Robert Reynolds at Bank
we have to find a way to basically shut
him down entirely because if Ronald
riddles basically dies or at least if
he's destroyed and that in turn would
lead to the Sentry kind of shutting down
as well technically they're not supposed
to exist in two physical forms this is
all kind of going on inside the mind of
Roberts like you have the century in the
real world and you've got Robert
Reynolds in the mind of in the mind of
the century you know so it's kinda one
of those crazy things while the century
is fighting is it's it's kind of hard to
grasp so so to explain this here while
the century is fighting scout in the
centuries own mind
crane EO is fighting Robert Reynolds
it's basically how this unfolding and so
the desire is okay try to find a way to
reverse the whole situation the issue
with this is that as Robert Reynolds
runs through his own mind as he's
running through and trying to figure out
a way to end all this the question he
asks is what if I been doing this wrong
all this time whenever I became the
century I was always afraid the void
would come back I was always afraid the
void would return so what if that's not
how things are supposed to be if the
void is all the darkness of this century
you know does this unrivaled power if
that's what the void is well then the
voids are part of everyone everybody's
got their darker side and so what he
does he sits down at reason he says if I
always avoided the void if I
try to keep him away that I'm incomplete
I am an incomplete being because I am
devoid of my darker side so what if I
allow that darker side in what if I join
that darker side what if the void and
the century and Robert Reynolds all
become one singular person then what
happens and that's one of those funny
things because the void doesn't talk
Robert riddles into it and so where this
fight is going on in the real world
between scout and century in the in the
centuries mine
Robert Reynolds merges with the void he
joins with the void and the void takes
over the century in his entirety and
when that happens the century is totally
reborn as a wholly new being the century
as he was supposed to exist and he looks
pretty badass
he looks pretty awesome the funny thing
about this is that when you're talking
about this century and the void you're
basically talking about some level of
power that was split in half and so if
they each had half of half of the power
they're supposed to have if the century
as powerful as he is was only ever half
as powerful as he was supposed to be and
the other half of that power resided and
avoid that when they joined together
this century's power as we've seen him
in Marvel Comics is essentially doubled
he's basically godlike in terms of his
abilities like the city becomes God is
basically what this is and we know this
because when you have scout who has the
power of the century as we've seen him
so far he's decimated by by the new
century
he's absolutely crushed and there's no
real hope there and so it's kind of
crazy because when Robert Reynolds
starts speaking to this count and says
look I can fix this I can help you I can
make you better
min Scout gives in and Robert riddles
breaks his neck he literally kills him
on the spot and so from there it turns
into I am basically calling for backup
and saying like we need the Avengers to
show up here and this is one of the
craziest scenarios you've got Thor
you've got Captain Marvel Carol Danvers
you've got she-hulk you've got Captain
America you've got some pretty big
hitters coming in from shield and we're
where she hoped jumps in and says okay
I've got this the responsibility juries
know you don't and you never did well
they eventually corner him after he
kills kills crania you know the response
is we can't just let you go and and and
then of course you basically says but
you can't stop me though there's no
conceivable way for the Avengers to stop
this new version of the century and I
would even ask the question could the
Incredible Hulk stop I mean if we're
talking about like part of the monster
Hulk probably world breaker Hulk I don't
think so because world breaker Hulk
literally thought century to a
standstill and then that's that's a
century before he received this power
boost and so now with his power boost by
the city it be almost night and day and
the century is twice as powerful as he
was before and the way he was before was
powerful enough to fight world breaker
Hulk to a standstill and that
stand the reason this century's twice as
powerful as world breaker Hulk so like
it gets kind of crazy when you get down
to this until like this new level of
power is this new level of godhood and
then it begs the question what the hell
happens next and that's the cool thing
about Jeff Lemire writing guys and
that's the great thing about it is so
long as he's on this title it'll go
through like twists and turns and all
kinds of different directions it'll be
awesome it'll be pretty sweet in terms
of how it all unfolds but that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]